regardez on a on a fait comme si vous
étiez dans pas trop incognito regardez
on a on a transformé Gilles Verdez
regardez ce que ça pourrait donner dans
le patron incognito
[Applaudissements]
mais pas mal limite frère tu es pas nul
mais sans déconner il fait beaucoup plus
gentil comme ça ouais
mais pourquoi tu te déguises pas et tu
vas avec Fatou au Sénégal c'est pas que
c'est toi
le dragon
c'est pas con regarde à Guillaume Genton
il est incroyable
[Applaudissements]
Texas
dit très fort Castaldi
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on dirait Super Nanny
c'est le vieux qui me dérange
allez et ils ont même eu ma
transformation des malades dépressifs
[Applaudissements]
vous tournera à droite des consignes
dès que possible jeudi
lui non mais lui je vous dis ça c'est
quelqu'un qui est à fleur de peau c'est
un écorché
là c'est l'écorché vif que vous voyez
c'est un truc c'est un truc de fou ok
celle-là quoi
c'est moi